YouTube has now so I dropped the panel  with Andrew Tate on  Christmas and today is the 26th I  dropped it on Christmas  it got a million views in a day which is  literally amazing  um and then YouTube decided to age  restrict my video meaning that they  everyone has to be signed in to watch it  which I don't think the majority of  people are signed in  um and it has to say that they're above  18 on their account so now the Matrix  The Matrix is  is coming for  my chat I would say more it's because  Andrew Tates in the video but  it's just  [Music]  um  a bit crazy that  you put all this work into a video just  for them to age restrict it but you know  um we're gonna be posting a lot of Clips  so you know what else can you do